this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below more on them in
a bit picture the richest person you can
possibly imagine
is it Jeff Bezos the super wealthy
Amazon founder or maybe it's Microsoft's
Bill Gates no matter who you choose
their wealth will still be peanuts next
to the subject of today's video Musa the
first was a man who's so wealthy that
the true extent of his riches are almost
indescribable the ruler of the Malian
empire from 1312 ad to around 1337 Musa
was a man whose life was built on gold
as King he personally owned over half of
the old world's known gold reserves on a
single trip through Cairo he once spent
so much that he caused the price of gold
to crash pushing Egypt into an economic
slump
imagine if auric Goldfinger somehow
mated with scrooge mcduck to produce the
wealthiest blingiest figure in history
well that would be Musa the first but
who really was this real-life King Midas
and where did his empire come from and
how did he amassed so much wealth born
in West Africa Musa inherited his
family's Kingdom only to expand it into
a vast empire at a time when Europe was
a land of peasants and warfare he
managed to build a cultural powerhouse
so great that it rivaled anywhere in the
known world a legendary figure in his
time often overlooked today this is the
tale of history's richest man
[Music]
the story of Musa the first technically
starts with his birth in 1280 ad to the
ruling clan of the Mali Empire but it
really starts way before that toward the
beginning of the 13th century was a very
different kind of birth the birth of an
empire in 1230 around fifty years before
Musa was born West Africa's dominant
state was the Garnon Empire but we only
mean dominance in terms of size founded
back in the 6th century Ghana was by now
the sick man of Africa an M bar that was
frail and teetering on the very edges of
death's door it would be mooses
great-uncle who would shove old man
Ghana over the threshold today little is
known about the early life of Sundiata
Keita
most of the stories about him come down
via oral traditions and seemed to be a
mix of fact and legend what we do know
is that Sundiata Kaieteur name which
means lion prince forged an alliance of
tribal leaders and Arab merchants in the
12 30s with one aim establishing a new
dominant power in West Africa this was
easier said than done
although Ghana was disintegrating there
was already a rival poised to take its
place the kingdom of saw so was rising
and it was primed to dominate the region
just as Ghana at once done this meant
any attempt by Sundiata to kill the
dying Empire might result in someone
else getting all its riches
so Sundiata decided he'd just have to
kill them both in 1235 Sundiata crushed
the armies of swords the epic battle of
Crenna
that done he pivoted and attacked Ghana
capturing its capital in 1240 in the
aftermath of Ghana's fall Sundiata
burned its capital to the ground
enduring over six centuries of history
from the ashes he built a new superpower
the likes of which Africa had never seen
the basic structure of Sundiata new
empire was an assembly of West African
Warriors and Arabic traders subordinate
to the supreme monarch ie Sundiata and
we really mean subordinates in this new
empire Sundiata z' word was final only
he was allowed to own gold nuggets and
every slave in his dominions was
personally loyal to him and
and while the new Empire's religion was
nominally Islam it was actually closer
to a godlike veneration of its leader
the name Mali even means the place where
the King lives while this might sounds
like Sundiata is setting himself up to
become kim jeong-hoon skinnier 13th
century cousin that's not what happens
while Cindy Arthur was certainly
egomaniacal
he knew his empire might crumble if he
went marching through Africa demanding
that everyone worship Him instead he set
about building a network of alliances
that would hold his empire together
you know today how the EU is technically
run out of Brussels but is really a
connection of autonomous states that
often just do their own thing well in a
very basic sense that was Cindy art as
Molly a huge decree of autonomy was
granted to its various regions with
Sundiata leaving them alone as long as
they kept passing on gold slaves and
taxes the hands-off approach works and
it's allowed Sundiata to bring useful
trade routes under his control by the
time the lion Prince kicked the bucket
around 12:55 the Malian Empire was the
largest Africa had ever seen yet even
this super state would only be a
footnote in what came next in just a few
short decades Musa was going to take his
great uncle's already pretty decent
Empire and make it truly great
[Music]
by the time Musa was born in 1218 the
might of Mali was well established some
D artists Empire controlled trade on
both the Niger and sankaranna rivers
with its now long lost capital of neon
II standing on the plains beside the
latter Mali also held an excellent
strategic position between the gold
fields of West Africa and the salt
trading caliphates of the north allowing
it to tax the heck out of both
commodities in fact the Empire damasc so
much gold that it traded it as far
afield as Venice and the kingdom of
Castile and this wealth really did
trickle down to the Empire's subjects
travelers at the time noted that there
was food in every village that the
justice system worked and that travel
between regions was easy
why are you I thinking well that's not
really impressive just remember that
Europe at this time is full of rampaging
Mongols killing everything in sight
while England is dividing its time
between war with the Scots and expelling
the Jews Mali in the 13th century guys
was really the place to be still we
don't want to give the impression that
Mali was the sole power in West Africa
at this stage the river port of Timbuktu
was still the most powerful and
cosmopolitan city for hundreds of
kilometers where everything from ivory
to textiles to spices were traded you
won't be surprised to him that this made
the rulers of Mali all sorts of jealous
but what were they going to do about it
while after soon the artists death Mali
had passed on to 8th succession of
rulers best described as being somewhere
between media currents well solid gold
dumbasses if the Empire of Mali wanted
to go down in history as more than just
a product of a single man it was going
to have to stop producing some decent
rulers like right now luckily its
greatest ruler was already waiting in
the wings
ok great we've established the world
that he lived in so now we can finally
start talking about the man himself Musa
was a guy who was never destined to be
king in the 1300s the throne actually
went to his brother Mansur Abu Bakkar
the seconds a guy with a vision to rival
Sundiata unfortunately that vision was
of how to write himself out of the
history books in the weirdest way
possible from the moment he took the
Abubakar was obsessed with the see
Molly's most westerly point reached the
Atlantic and it said Abu Bakr spent
years gazing at the ocean trying to
figure out what lay on the other side of
it eventually this obsession became a
plan which in turn became the bizarre
reality in 1312 abu bakr appointed
masseur regions to rein in his name and
he got on a ship at the head of a 2,000
strong fleet and accompanied by tens of
thousands of soldiers women and slaves
he set sail for the horizon none of
those 2,000 ships was ever seen again
today there are a very small number of
academics who think abu bakkar ii sailed
clear to the new world that he initiated
africa's first contact with the Americas
but there is no archaeological evidence
of this and it seems rather unlikely
although the Malians used ships they
weren't explorers preferring instead to
navigate up rivers and close to
coastlines when abu bakr vanished over
the horizon it's almost certain that the
only thing he discovered was how it
feels to die at sea back in Mali Musa
waited a few months for his brother to
return scanning the horizons for signs
of the fleet when he didn't Musa had
himself officially crowned Mansa Musa
the first it was an opportunistic power
grab nothing more a brother trying to
outshine his older sibling it was also
the start of Molly's rise to greatness
now if you'd like to have your own rise
to greatness the best way to facilitate
that is not sailing off into the
distance or trying to start an empire
it's getting a website with Squarespace
and I want to tell you about them before
we get into the rest of today's video
now two simple things one maybe you've
got some idea for a website or a
business or a YouTube channel a podcast
something like that well too the only
way to figure out if that's worth doing
is to get it out into the world and I
know that can be daunting because it's
scary to start new things but not
knowing how to set up a website is not
an excuse there are no excuses available
with Squarespace
Squarespace allows you to create a
beautiful website for whatever you're up
to if you want to sell something online
yes do it with Squarespace or if you're
starting a podcast they handle all of
that - doing a youtube channel I'll
obviously start the YouTube
but you're gonna want a website to
complement it it all starts on
Squarespace with a beautiful template
you can customize to your heart's
content or if you've got design skills
start from scratch I'd never do that
I've got no design skills I just use a
beautiful template and once you've gone
through the easy customization process
you didn't have to worry about updates
patches or any tank BS no one likes any
of that stuff and Squarespace they'll
school the website II stuff that you've
heard of mailing their social
integrations that kind of stuff all
handled so get started now there is a
link below or just go to Squarespace
comm forward slash buy a graphics and
you'll save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or a domain and let's get
back to Musa remember how we said Sunday
artists Molly was the biggest empire
Africa had ever seen
well Musa wouldn't be content with just
holding African Records he wanted to
compete with the entire known world
not long after assuming the throne Musa
raised an army of a hundred thousand men
and ten thousand horses he then headed
out and conquered the living crap out of
everything over the next decade or so
Musa managed to double Molly's size
under his watch the Empire grew to
include basically all of modern-day
Senegal and Gambia plus parts of Niger
Mauritania Mali Burkina Faso Guinea
Bissau
Guinea and the Ivory Coast by the time
he was done Mali stretched over 3,200
kilometers east to west or roughly the
distance from New York City to New
Mexico at that point the only larger
Empire on earth belonged to the Mongols
to consolidate his new lands Musa
divided his empire into 14 provinces and
placed each under the control of a local
father like Sundiata Musa gave his
father's a huge degree of autonomy
allowing them to preserve linguistic
religious and ethnic identities in the
newly conquered territories but like
Cindy otter
he also made sure that the farmers
autonomy came at a price gold as much
gold as they could get their grubby
hands on by now Molly's borders
encompassed half the world's known gold
reserves and Musa claimed all of this
for an
self along with taxes tariffs and slaves
he decreed that all goals not in the
form of dust should go to him and him
alone throughout history there have been
some incomprehensible wealthy people the
Roman Emperor Augustus would be worth
over 4.6 trillion dollars in today's
money during his reign the Chinese
emperor Shen Zhong of Seong controlled
up to 25% of global GDP but not even
these two combines could hold a candle
to Musa the First's gold stuffed
pantaloons yet despite being so rich he
could buy and sell mr. burns 10 times
over Musa was almost completely
anonymous outside of West Africa the
Malian Empire was nearly unknown except
to traders in a handful of European and
Arabic cities but if the rest of the
world still thought of West Africa is
nothing but jungle they were about to
get a very rude awakening so we haven't
made a big deal out of it so far but you
might recall us mentioning that Marley's
official religion was easel on well just
like now Islam in the 14th century was
super hot on the Hajj the idea that
every Muslim should go to Mecca at least
once in their lives Mali and Kings
before Mercer had done so but they
tended to travel in small groups
befitting pilgrims in 1324 Musa decided
it was time to do his hand but he was
gonna do it in a group befitting not a
pilgrim but a king and in particular
this King the richest guy who ever lived
it was a decision that would cause a
sensation in July that year Musa set off
from his empire at the head of a caravan
of 60,000 men they were court official
soldiers traditional singers known as
gree arts merchants camel drivers women
there were 12,000 slaves and tens of
thousands of sheep for food a hundred
camels brought up the rear and every
single living thing was absolutely
covered in gold
imagine the archetype of a mid-90s West
Coast rapper barely able to move beneath
his bling well that guy would have
looked underdressed next to even mooses
lowliest servant everyone was wearing
gold brocade and luxury Persian silk the
first 500 slaves additionally each
carried 3 kilos of solid gold each of
the 100 camels was loaded down with 135
kilos of gold
thousands of horses hauls the finest
textiles in Africa it was a cavalcade of
wealth the procession of such riches
that it probably looked like a mobile
Fort Knox and when word of it finally
reached Arabia and Europe it was going
to up ends everything people thought
they knew although Musa was traveling at
the head of a caravan made entirely of
bling a van didn't mean his mission was
totally peaceful on roots in Mecca he
detoured to the Songhai Kingdom and
conquered it adding several hundred
square kilometers to his empire as Zia
do the conquest finally brought Timbuktu
in tamales folds adding that city's
immense wealth to mooses pocketbook
still this spit of recreation or
conquering was just a sideshow what
really caused a storm was when Musa and
his entourage arrived in Cairo in 1324
Cairo was meant to be the richest city
in Africa ruled over by the great Sultan
Al malik al nasir a dude who was himself
no stranger to wealth but when mooses
entourage came marching in waving more
gold than anyone had ever seen even the
Sultan had to stoop to pick up his jaw
from the ground mooses first act was to
send the Sultan 50,000 gold dinars
simply as a way of saying hi effectively
handing him over 210 kilograms of gold
just to make sure we're clear on how
crazy this is a kilo of gold today
retails for roughly fifty thousand
dollars and Moosa had handed over 210 to
the Sultan while basically saying oh
this it's just a little something to say
thanks great city you've got here by the
way but while you are I would probably
be pretty darn excited to receive that
amount of gold in Cairo it actually
caused a major diplomatic incidents
after receiving mooses gift sultan al
malik al nasir demanded the Malian King
come over to meet him but since this
would involve Musa having to kiss the
ground before the Sultan as a mark of
respect
Musa refused the standoff essentially
I'm more important though I'm more
importance God so heated that it briefly
looks like a rioters gonna break out in
Cairo but in the end Musa swallowed his
pride he went to the Sultan and he
kissed the ground in return the Sultan
opened Cairo to Musa as his personal
playground the Malians
wound
staying three months in the city living
in a vast palace that the Sultan put
aside for them every day Musa would go
out and wander the city of nearly 1
million souls and every day he would
hand out his gold like the Nuggets were
tic-tacs at the same time his entourage
were going through the markets buying
all the stuff that they couldn't get at
home seeing all these super-rich Malians
the Egyptian merchants marked up their
prices when the Marlins paid regardless
they marked them up again and again and
again soon Cairo was swimming in gold
stories of mooses largesse worth fanning
out across the trade routes bringing
more and more people to the city
unfortunately Musa was maybe a little
too generous you may have heard the
story about how during the Spanish
conquest of Latin America the
conquistadors brought so much gold back
to Spain the price crashed
well what hundreds of conquistadors did
to Spain Musa did to Cairo all by
himself his generosity so flooded the
market that over 20% was wiped off the
value of gold the result was an economic
slump that Cairo wouldn't recover from
for 12 years but it's doubtful Musa even
noticed the chaos he caused after three
months is entourage marched out of Cairo
and on to Mecca leaving only glittering
memories and a gold induced hangover
although Cairo would ultimately suffer
from its flooded gold market the crash
made mooses reputation in Europe people
finally started hearing about the king
who was so wealthy his supply of gold
never ran out from that point on mooses
name would pass into legend
[Music]
when moosa' finally reached arabia he
kept right on throwing his gold about
like some kind of Vegas High Roller he
bought up land splashed cash on houses
from aliens to stay in on future
pilgrimages but he also took time out
from flooding the gold markets to check
out Mecca sites its mosques and minarets
schools and libraries evidently Musa
liked what he saw when the Marlins
finally left Arabia in 1325 musa didn't
just believe a good Muslim he left as a
good Muslim with a plan a plan to turn
the Mauryan Empire into a cultural
powerhouse to rival Mecca and while is
insane wealth may be why everyone
remembers him today it was this decision
more than anything which would lead to
his lasting legacy
the first thing Moussa did was use his
vast wealth to tempt as many Islamic
scholars from Mecca as he could find the
group of intellectuals he netted even
included direct descendants of the
Prophet Muhammad earning the Malian King
serious bragging rights that done Musa
set off in his Caravan and headed back
to Cairo the Egyptian city was still
suffering the after-effects of his last
visit but Musa wasn't there to cause
another economic slump no he was back
for one man one man in a city of almost
a million people a man known as abu
ishaq altitude in a poet and architect
from Moorish Spain out who din was
something of a cairo celebrity and he
might have remained had Musa not dumped
200 kilograms of gold at his feet and
declared the architect could keep all of
that plus dozens of slaves plus a swath
of lands along the Niger River
if only he came to work for Mali when
mooses Caravan left Cairo shortly after
well he went with him in the conquered
kingdom of Songhai there lay a city with
immense wealth known as Timbuktu
artisans job was to take that city and
transform it into a glistening pearl on
the river a town to rival Mecca in its
grandeur to make that happen it first
have to build the greatest mosque Africa
had ever seen today the dingo ABBA
mosque is recognized as an architectural
masterpiece protected by UNESCO it's
known for its soaring mud brick
architecture with exposed wooden beams
and minarets that look like pyramids
built by adding layer upon layer of
until it finally took shape it has
absolutely nothing in common with the
grand white stone mosques of Morocco or
Turkey and yet it's this simple style
and use of cheap materials that make it
so beautiful employing tradesmen from as
far away as Yemen outed and built a
mosque using the same techniques and
materials as the poor in Timbuktu used
to build their homes in doing so he
created a building both sacred and
accessible the building that continues
to function as a mosque to this very day
it probably says something this when
al-qaeda took over Timbuktu in 2012 and
set about blowing up all traces of
Malian past they still couldn't bring
themselves to destroy this mosque but
the de Jing grabber mosque wasn't the
only thing Musa brought to Timbuktu
under his watch that city was
rejuvenated already a wealthy port it
soon became peppered with library
schools and the foundations of
universities Musa through goals at the
Arts at culture and soon a 14th century
Timbuktu was what Paris was to the 19th
century in short this great city in this
great Empire became the focal point of
an entire continent while it would never
quite achieve mooses dream of rivaling
Mecca sure as how came close
unfortunately though this greatness it
wasn't destined to last in its lifetime
the Malian Empire never really achieved
greatness in and of itself instead it
just had the luck to be blessed with two
great rulers Sundiata and Musa who
separately managed to take it to its
height when Sundiata finally died Mali
had stagnated but when Musa died it
would be so long Mali
in 1337 Musa the first passed away of
natural causes he left behind an empire
at its height and a throne which would
make anyone who sat on it the richest
person in existence and therein lay the
problem
no one could decide who got to sit on
their throne
way back when Sundiata established his
empire he hadn't written into law the
firstborns rights of secession this was
fine when everyone got on and agreed who
should be king but when they didn't it
had only one painfully obvious outcome
civil war in the wake of mooses death
the Marlene Empire began it's depressing
decline barely was the greatest mansur
in the grounds than various provinces
split off or declared themselves in
rebellion or got sucked into squabbles
between would be rulers Bob Marley
itself would survive over another
century it never again covered such an
extent as in mooses day never again made
its ruler quite so wealthy the final
collapse came in the mid 15th century
new gold fields were discovered while at
the same time new trade routes opened up
across Africa robbing Molly of both
precious metals and taxes by 1464 the
once subordinate Songhai kingdom had not
just declared independence but it had
grown so strong that its rulers were
able to attack and overrun what remained
of molly absorbing its riches into their
own Kingdom and because the song I were
apparently total dicks their conquest
included ransacking Timbuktu five
separate times until almost nothing
remained of mooses great city a mere two
hundred years after it first come into
existence the story of Molly was over at
last but not the story of Musa back in
1375 a Swedish geographer had heard
tales of Musa stay in Cairo and been so
inspired by the gold King that he
created history's first serious map of
West Africa that map has included an
image of Musa clutching a vast gold
nugget looking like a figure from
fantasy and it would be this image more
than anything else that would inspire
the generations to come right up until
the 18th century
Timbuktu was the Eldorado of Africa a
place of legend where the streets women
to be paved with gold tales of this
a mystical city inspired many people to
explore the gold coast transforming
European understanding of Africa and
what are the Timbuktu they finally found
wasn't quite the city of myth it was
still home to one of the greatest
examples of religious architecture in
history the story of Musa the first then
is certainly a tale of unimaginable
riches I mean this guy's gold crashed an
entire economy but it's also the tale of
an African king who built an empire that
could rival any in Europe or Asia
a man who patronized learning and
culture in a region those elsewhere
wrote off as a place of savages he might
be semi forgotten now but Musa the first
of Mali remains one of history's great
leaders next time you see modern
billionaires like Jeff Bezos Warren
Buffett or Donald Trump on TV
just remember the king who was richer
than them all and the great African city
that he used those riches to build so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below also support
this show by supporting our fantastic
sponsor Squarespace who I'm linking to
you below and thank you for watching
[Music]